I have fun be safe and call me when you
get there and bear it there and back hey
boys night out at Disneyland months at
the latest is 11
hey guys so I felt it was only right and
I could only do it justice if I made an
entire video about why mana is important
to me because originally we were
thinking about merging both videos which
is Disneyland and me going to the manag
concert with the girls in one video
because it did end up end up happening
in one day but I think it's important to
really put out there the reason why my
knifes so important to me and I've
actually been so nervous to film this
video because it's just like I think the
subject of my dad is like probably like
the most vulnerable side of me um so
yeah I got daddy issues
but um man I just started this video and
I'm already trying to fight back the
tears modes and I are pretty lit we're
gonna continue to face these colds and
she has to pee I had to pee too as well
but Casey Isaac and Adrian are still it
didn't happen oh my god I didn't see my
breathe girl breathe so Maya is
considered Latin America's most
successful band of all time the main
singer he's from the same area of Mexico
that my dad is from so back in the day
my dad used to tell me that they would
play at this auditorium space like where
a lot of bands played near his house
where he grew up which is my grandma's
house and so he would go listen to them
before they were even a big thing so my
dad was an early adopter of Moana and so
he's a really big fan so for me growing
up like my not
like instilled in me like insanely
instilled so when Bo's told us that she
was able to get us tickets I was like
you have no idea Bo's you have no idea
what this means to me
we're trying to find our way $300 we got
floor seats baby both yeah I love you
you literally can't see me this is bad
listen
[Applause]
I'm gonna die I'm gonna die I'm
literally gonna die okay I'm not gonna
die I'm gonna stay alive thank you deal
I'm gonna stay alive
Oh goddamn the sword sorry guys this is
really really hard for me to talk about
um but I really feel it's so important
for me to just put it out there as like
a sort of like healing for me
so geo and Stacy and I both like we all
went together and we had such a great
time in right before like I had drank a
bit at Disneyland so I showed up a
little bit already tipsy you know it's
awesome cuz if you guys watch my stories
my lyft driver from Disneyland to
Stacy's house he was also my not a fan
and he was blasting my novel hallway
there so I'm like oh my god dude you're
getting such a huge tip like this is so
fun so it was really awesome on my way
there so once I get there Stacy is like
dude we got to get some drinks and I'm
like girl I'm Way ahead of you but sure
I'm down cuz I like I like to have a
good time right so and then plus like I
really felt just like this video I
needed to try right before I did this
cuz like for some reason like I need
that liquid courage you know when it
comes to this topic for me um so then we
ended up getting to the concert when
we're heading down and I see like the
Minot signed and everything and like I
see the stage I'm just like woah this is
real this is happening holy crap this is
I'm really about to witness this this is
amazing and I just have like this like
I'm just like I'm flooded with
excitement and love for the girls that
I'm with as Casey mentioned in the other
video when I was telling him about mine
on like the experience I had with my
sisters like I remember being little and
there was this one night where I was
spending when I was spending the summer
in Mexico we were listening to swingers
Lee kilos which is one of my nose albums
I was asking my sister is like hey what
does this word mean and what does that
word mean and what does this other word
mean they were translating it to me like
trying to help me understand Spanish
vocabulary but yeah so that was like a
really beautiful bonding moment that I
had with my sisters and especially with
that song like how Casey was kind of
tying it back in where it's like I had
that connection with my sisters then and
then now my new sisters I get to
experience going to the concert with
them now so it was really it was a
beautiful night so I think I maybe made
it like about three or four songs into
the concert before I just like I
couldn't hold it in and I was just like
cry um because okay my mom liked their
songs like about 90% of their songs are
about love and about like relationships
or it's about like finding their love
like their love is gone and like they're
trying to find their love or about how
like heartbreak because of a lost love
and so this one song it's literally
about like how their heart hasn't
stopped raining and so that moment I was
just like whoa I can't hold this in so I
started crying my eyes out and they
started thinking about my dad my parents
they split up they got a divorce when I
was seven that was in 1997 so that same
year my neck came out with this album
called sueños Aghios and my dad gave me
the CD right around the time when they
split up and he would tell me hey you
know like listen to this album and when
I relist into it think of me I've kept
that CD over the years and also around
that time he would send me postcards and
stuff and he would send me photos in the
mail but he would like pretty much write
like hey this is Fort if in case my mom
opened it and so there was a one time
where he sent photos where he met fed
and Alex from - it was the lead singer
of the band there's my dad fan boy this
is the drummer Alex
here's another photo of him with fed and
so on the back of these two photos he
wrote a really beautiful message that I
did it that I totally forgot that these
photos had until I was getting ready for
this video and I pulled out these photos
and I finally turned them around because
I've always had them in an album and I
turned them around and I read the
message and like I just wrote down so
this one it says it says this photo it's
all in Spanish
this photo is for Tiffany from birth
away at them make it go
I miss you your dad and fed from enough
they say hello and I told them that I
have a daughter that loves me I love
Google which is a song that manaro or
like that they have or it's about like
this this boy who is talking to his
cuckoo clock and telling the cuckoo
clock like hey um my dad is gone can you
turn on the light but stop time it
pretty much it's like a song about how
their dad is gone and so this song was
so appropriate because my parents had to
split up and they had such an ugly
divorce where it was um it was really
ugly so we were like I couldn't see my
dad and so that's why it it's so
emotionally scarring where I'm 30 years
old now like almost 30 and I still can't
get over it the reason why this affects
me times 10 then it would about maybe a
year and a half ago is because this
January it's gonna be one year since I
found out that my dad
has been missing so he he has lived in a
hard life um a really rocky one and but
he's never done this he's never just
disappeared from the family but by the
time I found out which was January last
year he had already been missing for
five months but my family didn't want to
worry me so they kind of kept it from me
to not keep me worried so I've taken a
whole year to really try to process this
and try to deal with it on my own terms
and you know I've been to therapy and
stuff and it's just really really really
hard when there's no conclusion to what
you're going through
so I decided for myself that because my
life is so public and you know I think
it's for me it's sort of therapeutic in
a way for me to kind of just put it all
out there and just let it not weigh so
heavily on me anymore I think um I've
already kind of accepted that he's
probably gone but I think by just kind
of holding it in it kind of kept me from
fully getting closure with it by me
going to this concert and by me Tony
BAE's all this it really feels like I'm
just kind of like it's like
ahead of me now and it's out there hope
my dad's okay I miss him I love him the
last time I saw him was when you guys
saw which was we all went to Mexico and
I think that the hardest part of all
this is that my entire life I've always
called my dad so high and he's always
been on this really high pedestal for me
he's always been like my hero that I
would see sporadically throughout my
life because he always gave me so much
love and he always made me feel like
that was the most important person ever
in the whole world in his life and I
think that's why I held him so dear to
my heart and obviously he's my dad it
was just that the last time we saw each
other things didn't end very well and I
was like the only time ever in my life
we've ever not had a good time with each
other so I think that's why it kind of
hurts even more knowing that keeps bond
but I just gotta get it out there so
it's not on my back anymore
and this is my way of dealing with it so
ready for whatever may come from me
doing this and putting it out there
because I've prepared myself for over a
year for this is just I'm still really
emotional because obviously it still
really affects me he's my dad he's gone
and I feel like it's important for me to
do this so that's the reason why my
night means so much to me guys and the
cure as well and that's why I cried my
eyes out when I was at that concert
because I feel like his spirit like his
being somehow lives within their music
so even before finding out he
disappeared like I've always felt like
and he's always been with me through the
music so this is like me like cleansing
myself so I need to cry I need to let it
out
I need to let you guys know and I just
this is this is my way of dealing with
it so I was hoping I can get through
this video at least halfway through
without having to cry but yeah it's just
cute seeing my dad fanboy it was also so
sweet I have to mention um when I was
like cry my eyes out Gio
she kept hugging me and it was so sweet
she kept comforting me she's such a good
friend and so is Stacy and so with boats
cuz they all they were all hooking me
sorry if I made you guys cry I didn't
mean to um I didn't mean to cry either
okay I'll finish this I'll see you guys
in the next video
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]